hi Erica I'm Shannon Hertzfeld from
Archer Daniels Midland company you asked
a good question booth which is what's my
vision progressed in my life you know
every day this planet adds two hundred
thousand foot wrong person every day and
so I start thinking about what does this
will really look like as day by day year
by year we keep adding hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people how do I
introduce what should I do to make sure
that their lives are flourishing are
filled with the kind of bounty that my
life over my relatively short lifespan
bear cub has been able to accomplish
part of what I spend a lot of time doing
is making sure that the very basics are
attended to that people are who were
born today are able to get access to
good food to to clean water and to the
opportunities that I've enjoyed that my
family has a Jordan I think being here
in Davos I've come away with the new
optimism Giroux that the private sector
like my company has an awful lot to
contribute but that we cannot do it
alone that there are government's that
are very interested in we're partnering
and that there are parts of civil
society who have been enormous
contributors to help us work better to
find those places are your collar ground
or to make sure that put the 200,000
people that were born today their lives
will be as rich as full of opportunities
as mine never been and in fact that the
world will be in a better place they